المخلوق جين كارتر الذي تجسست عبر
نافذتها في داربيشاير إنجلترا يعطي
معنى جديدًا لمصطلح foxtrot ثم
وقف على ساقيه الأماميتين ولم
أستطع تصديق أن عيناي تجلب
هاتف الكاميرا بسرعة وصرخت
لزوجها هناك ثعلب ذو قدمين
العشب كان رائعًا جدًا في الواقع
مثل The Fantastic Mr Fox الذي
لا يمكننا تخيل رد فعله سوى نجاح باهر
السيد The Fantastic Mr Fox تعامل أيضًا مع الخسارة.
ظل الثعلب ذو الأرجل على هذا
النحو طوال حياته لأنه يبدو أنه
يتكيف جيدًا ولم تكن هناك علامات
إصابة ولكنه كان جائعًا ذهبت إلى
المطبخ وفتحت علبة من الرسائل
غير
المرغوب فيها  في
النهاية ، أمسك الثعلب ذو الأرجل
بجزء كبير من الرسائل غير المرغوب فيها واندفع
بسرعة أنه كان
سريعًا
بصراحة ، لقد كان أمرًا لا يصدق على الإنترنت
، أصبح الثعلب ذو الأرجل أسطورة فورية ، وعلى
الرغم من أن البعض قد يضحك ، فقد
وجد البعض الآخر أنه من المحزن ليس جين لماذا ليس
هذا محزن
لأنه كان
يعتني بأشياءه وبدا بصحة جيدة مع حركات أكثر
إثارة للإعجاب من الثعلب الراقص في
ما يقوله الثعلب
أغرب شيء رأيته في
حياتي وكم من الوقت كانت حياتك على طول
واحد عاش الاثنان  -لغد فوكس طالما
أنه يبتعد عن البريد المزعج أتمنى له التوفيق يا شباب
CNN نيويورك
[موسيقى]